the bags of goods the train was
transporting are still strewn across the
railway track after friday's accident in
southeast democratic republic of congo
authorities say the train lost control
because of a traction problem several of
its 15 carriages crashed down an
embankment dozens of people were killed
and more than a hundred injured
we'd been traveling for three days we
noticed the train was not moving
properly all of a sudden our carriage
disconnected from the main part of the
train and we started falling backwards
we couldn't even jump out we ended up
crashing into the bush
the freight train was travelling to
lubumbashi in the south east the third
largest congolese city it's near the
zambian border and well known for its
mining industry on board were hundreds
of passengers who authorities say
shouldn't have been there
this accident involved a freight train
not a passenger train each month we run
four services including one for
passengers unfortunately most of the
time people prefer to catch the freight
train
train derailments are frequently
reported in this region because of
poorly maintained tracks and facilities
often there aren't enough passenger
trains so people use freight trains to
travel long distances the victims
families say that's led to a tragedy
that should have been prevented victoria
gatenbee al jazeera